[Musique]
celle ci
non
[Musique]
mais
à
[Applaudissements]
regardez un visiteur plus grand qu'à la
voilà bien ici
regardez ça vous avez déjà vu quelqu'un
d'aussi gants
bonjour bonjour monsieur pour vous on ne
pourrait pas causer une tombe
suffisamment grande
même avec une pelleteuse je rentrerai là
dedans je vous jure
désolé on n'a pas de sac oeil à votre
taille ce jeune homme vous emmener à vos
tombes
allons-y
mais tu l'as vu à la à là bas avec eux
[Musique]
je suis né en 1954 je suis agent
funéraire depuis 60 ans je travaille 24
heures sur 24
on dit que quand la vie devient trop
dure il faut se rendre dans un cimetière
ouadhias à l'âme est immense c'est le
plus grand cimetière au monde tout le
mondre position m comme serviteur ils
viennent de toutes les provinces d'irak
et même d'autres pays quand j'étais
enfant je venais souvent au cimetière
avec mon père je croisais les dombes
avec lui puis j'ai repris le travail de
mon père comme il avait repris autrefois
le métier de mon grand-père ici ici mais
le ici ensuite j'ai fait l'armée pendant
douze ans de service militaire
obligatoire et deux ans de réserve
c'était comme ça pour ceux nés en 1954
ma je n'ai jamais essayé d'échapper à la
conscription dans l'armée irakienne à la
halle à mada si je ne défends pas mon
peuple qui le fera les bleus mais le sur
le dos doucement la guerre iran irak a
duré de 1980 à 1988 et j ai pris part
par la roma plaît la terreur des
mortiers et offre des mortiers
rave je n'avais peur de rien les obus
tombés tout autour de moi mais je reste
et je me souviens qu'on avait passé 56
jours sous terre
on ne sortait que la nuit comprenez leur
position à midi et à 12h05 les iraniens
la reprenait on évacuer les morts et les
blessés on se regroupait et on réattaque
et une fois j'ai essayé d'éteindre
l'incendié d'un char pour sauver les
blessés mais les obus ont explosé de mon
bras j'ai essayé de me protéger des
éclats mais mon visage a été touché
voilà pourquoi je suis comme ça même
quand je servais dans l'armée je
creusais des tombes au cimetière pendant
mes permission attention mamie ma mère
là bas
quand une personne meurt ses parents
amis et voisins ne s'approchent pas du
canal
ils ont peur je n'ai pas peur de la mort
j'ai fait la guerre
j'ai tout vu j'ai tué des iraniens moi
je suis au mortier
les amis tombent autour de moi certains
sont tués d'autres blessés certains
faits prisonniers
à partir du moment où c'est devenu une
routine mon coeur s'est endurci
[Musique]
jean terles est mort c'est mon les
enterrons depuis plus de 300 ans
génération après génération notre vie en
[Musique]
pendant la guerre irak iran j'en tirais
entre 5 et 9 personnes par jour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pendant la guerre du golfe atteignent en
inhumé entre 3 et 4 tous les jours
[Musique]
m
du temps des américains adieu salam
c'était tendu il y avait régulièrement
des funérailles
j'en enterré quatre à cinq jours et
nuits
où
lifeco baisse est apparue il ya eu
beaucoup de morts à voir j'en intérêts 5
4 parfois deux ou trois
[Applaudissements]
27 ans de bep on n'enterre pas beaucoup
une ou deux personnes du théâtre il y
avait plus de travail pendant la guerre
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'enterrement d'un martyr c'était
le commandant de l'unité d'intervention
rapide de sahraj al salam à samara ils
ont été attaqués hier
[Musique]
c'est vrai c'est la masse salariale sans
même a été formé après l'invasion de
l'irak par des chants 2014 martyrs a été
abattu par des tireurs d'élite mais
criminelle de l'état islamique
[Musique]
oh mon père
à mon frère
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr on voit déjà sa lame est un
endroit célèbre il existe depuis plus de
mille ans les prophètes de dieu ont été
les premiers à avoir été enterrés ici
cela m'a dû faire face à des
transformations au fil du temps il s'est
notamment étendu après l'invasion de
l'irak par les forces d'occupation par
les troupes américaines et celles de
leurs alliés pas des irakiens ont salué
les troupes américaines quand elles sont
entrés en irak
j'espérais qu'elle allait libérer l'irak
de saddam hussein après la chute de
saddam qu'elles sont restés en irak
les militaires ont fait des choses
terribles il incitait à la haine et
semer la discorde entre chiites et
sunnites
c'est alors que le terrorisme est apparu
c'est devenu une guerre civile
puis l'état islamique est arrivé alors
que ouadhias salam dans la ville sainte
de nadjaf a commencé à 5 ans 10 ans
bah son compte en banque après la chute
du régime
j'ai été arrêté par les militaires
américains
à l'époque j'étais gardien de but dans
un garage je me trouvais au garage on
faisait un raid dans certaines maisons
et ils m'ont trouvé bon capturés ils
m'ont bandé les yeux et lee côté j'ai
été détenu pendant un an
trois mois et 17 jours ils m'ont soumis
à toutes sortes de tentures ça sans même
savoir pourquoi l'habitude on tente sur
les criminels pour qu'ils avouent leurs
crimes
mais moi j'étais tentures et sans être
interrogé sans but précis
au bout d'un an trois mois et 17 jours
m'ont livré aux autorités irakiennes
tu me relâcher car je n'avais commis
aucun crime je n'était coupable de rien
alors que l'armée de l'imam mahdi que la
paix soit avec lui a été créé afin de
résister aux envahisseurs
[Musique]
avant ne battait pas contre les
américains après ce qu'ils ont fait j'ai
pris les armes
ils sont devenus mes ennemis et si vous
allez au cimetière là où les martyrs de
l'armée du mahdi oppose
je vous verrai l'ampleur du désastre il
ya des tombes de vieux comme de jeunes
jeu merci nous les avons vaincus et
chasser de notre pays
mon frère mon frère moi et j'espère que
l'irak se stabilisera que nous serons
tous frères qu'il n'y aura aucune
animosité entre nous au canada
j'espère que nous allons revenir au bon
vieux temps oh mon frère
m
[Musique]
bazzanella rappelant que les étrangers
se mêleront de nos affaires en irak
il y aura toujours des victimes mais
quand notre pays retrouvera sa stabilité
et que les étrangers partiront il y aura
moins de morts pour ça ne pourra
s'arrêter que comme ça à l'eau
on est en route pour les funérailles
encore une guerre tous ici d'accord
aux femmes
là ce travail est pas comme ça à pas
comme ça remet la tombe en place
[Applaudissements]
il n'y a pas d'autre dieu qu'allah
et maman maman
[Applaudissements]
que la paix soit avec vos parents s'il
vous plaît laissez les travailler
je le tuerais
ils n'ont jamais vu un mort que dieu
bénisse votre père et votre mère prions
pourquoi faire ça les morts doivent être
enterrés le documentaire avec elle
comment ça
[Applaudissements]
ouais
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout le monde est
derrière
me frapper poussée est jetée de la terre
je continuais simplement à travailler
ce n'était pas la première fois après
ils se sont excusés en disant qu'il
n'avait jamais vécu une telle situation
auparavant ils enterraient leurs mères
bien aimé qu'on te frappe ou non peu
importe ce sont leurs proches tout ce
qu'ils peuvent voir ces leurs parents
être mis en terre être recouverts de
terre devant leurs yeux c'est choquant
comprenons et l'acceptons ouais ce
charpentier
c'est habib et son frère abbas habib mon
cher
[Musique]
ps je m'appelle habib j'ai 20 ans j'ai
abandonné l'école lorsque j'étais en
sixième
pas parce que je n'aimais pas cela ou
parce que je ne voulais pas faire mes
études mais mon père a dit et avait
besoin d'être charmant
tempère c'est quand le plus enterrement
pendant la guerre iran irak contre le
koweit où pendent h pendant la guerre
irano irakienne
chaque fois que j'essayais de me reposer
un peu quelqu'un venait me dire viens
avec nous s'il te plaît il faut encore
enterrer quelqu'un alors je mettais de
corps sur mon dos je prenais mes outils
et le traîner à travers les tranchées
une fois je n'ai pas pu partir à temps
alors j'ai dû passer toute la nuit parmi
les cadavres
mes amis sont venus ils n'ont pas
remarqué que j'étais dans la tombe et
ils m'ont versé un seau d'eau je m'en
suis x rp pour les insulter mais il
s'était enfui
ce n'est pas encore l'heure de mes
funérailles
quand j'avais 10 ou 12 ans j'ai commencé
à aider mon père à faire ce travail
au début c'était un peu effrayant
j'étais quelque peu perplexe je ne
pouvais pas oublier les morts mais je me
suis habitué avec le temps on nous
appelle les fils du cimetière les
fossoyeurs
beaucoup sont passés entre mes mains
certains ont été tués d'autres sont
décédés de mort naturelle
l'espoir terrain glissements de terrain
de mon côté oui sauf que tu te sortent
de là si tu finis enterré remonte comme
cela emploi
m tu fais quoi mon frère n'a jamais
creusé regarde comparé ta tombe à la
mienne tombe est immense ils disent que
le défunt est grand il est grand
qu'est-ce qui va pas chez toi hussein
d'abord je la longe comme ça puis le met
là dedans en l'orientant vers la mecque
et l'imam ali
la bien me remplacer tu va creuser à ma
place des 100 ne marche pas là-dessus
compris oui entendu
la tornade qui est là avec le cercueil
le cercueil remonte son visage sera
tournée vers la mecque monsieur
le passé avec la tête de ce côté là le
tient le sortait le tir et le allez vous
faire un noeud fait un nul
une fois que ce soit le sable ne cesse
de retomber tu m'entends
doucement doucement
que la baie la bénédiction soient sur
mahomet sa maison ce n'est pas si simple
d'enterrer une personne j'apprends
quelque chose des morts de la façon dont
ils sont décédées peu importe qu'ils
étaient un homme juste où un pêcheur
lisant la prière alpha qu'il ya donc
plus tard j'ai commencé à travailler au
cimetière des martyrs
il ya eu beaucoup de cas étrange le plus
grand choc a été l'arrivée de l'état
islamique en irak
il ya eu beaucoup de martyrs deux ou
trois frères dont un cousin a été
décapité un autre des membres et ils
avaient tous entre 20 et 25 ans et en
tant que fossoyeur j'ai été outré
bouleversé avant des ch
nous avions en moyenne une centaine
d'enterrement par jour et quand ils sont
arrivés il y en avait 300 ou 400 par
jour des morts provenant de tout le pays
les fossoyeurs reçoivent les terrains de
l'état et les gens viennent nous acheter
des concessions elle coûte de 2500 1,29
me 350 dollars ça dépend
certains est riche de gros monument pour
leurs proches d'autres choisissent de
petites pierres tombales en vertu de la
charia
chacun a sa propre conception combien tu
gagnes par mois 4 400 500 dollars
parfois 840 ça dépend bonsoir je suis
venu pour vous trouver une place ici
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
on y est presque qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
décent et regarde ce qu'il y à là tu l'a
mal fait
il faut aplanir il va falloir déborder
un peu sur leurs lots non diluée à faris
abbas les hommes de nadjaf sont de vrais
hommes
une crème rien toutes les provinces sauf
à vrai dire je veux quitter l'irak pour
aller vivre ailleurs et ne jamais
revenir
pourquoi non car c'est mieux à
l'étranger
je ne partirai jamais nous aimons l'irak
et vous vous ne l'aimez pas il n'aime
pas l'irak sutton homme à femmes si je
laime mais je veux du changement les
gens veulent du changement pas rester
toujours au même endroit
quant à moi si je pars ce sera peut-être
pour dix jours
puis je reviendrai mais bon il n'y a pas
de meilleur endroit que l'irak est
vraiment je me suis ennuyé à bagdad
je me suis mieux senti en retournant à
nadjaf
à voir
où allons nous finir nous tous c'est à
cela que ensemble afin de tous ne le
fait pas comme ça il faut que ça soit
plus large de ce côté comme cette tombe
là vous voyez on ne peut pas y aller
vous avez vu ce terrain c'est ça alors
on voit un autre ça ne va pas ce n'est
pas bon on est là comme ça regardez
comment les autres sont posés les sont
les fossoyeurs décider allons-y
allez on y va
il
enlève la terre abbas et qu'est-ce que
je fais là tu ne fais pas ça bien je la
fais plus étroite en bas la tombe est
trop large de la grandit pas je te dis
qu'ils apportent le corps
b
monde
[Musique]
l émirat l'iim d'habitat libre que la
paix soit avec lui dit ô croyants fait
une promesse l'un à l'autre non merci
j'ai pas soit tension
[Musique]
sachez good serviteur d'allah et fils de
son serviteur liasse m
fils de mahomet ces temps derniers jours
en ce monde est ton premier jour dans
l'autre monde
quand j'ai du temps libre je me lave je
me change et je sors avec mes amis
parfois je prends dix jours de congé et
je voyage dans d'autres pays en iran en
syrie en turquie
il faut changer de décor de temps en
temps ne pas toujours être au milieu des
tombes
alors la mer allons-y zim cieux je veux
vivre là bas près de la réserve de
poisson banane
tu vois la dernière colline oui ah oui
je vois je n'aurais pas grand chose une
petite maison palombe en bois pour ma
bien aimée et pour moi c'est bien je
vous jure c'est tout ce que je souhaite
si j'ai des enfants je ne les
appliquerait pas dans ce travail
cela n'a aucun avenir il ya des
perspectives pour ceux qui font leurs
études et veulent devenir médecin
officiers capitaine ou avocat je fais ça
non pas par choix mais parce que mon
papa était fatigué et avait besoin d
aide
[Musique]
parfois on attend dans une procession
funèbre
j'imagine qu'un jour je serai aussi
ensevelies ils vont faire avec moi la
même chose que nous faisons avec ses
morts je mens veloppe dans un linceul
je me couche là et je me figure à quoi
ça ressemble comment on se sent alain
mais je prends du recul avec cette
sensation mais il finira tous il n'y a
qu'une seule voie
[Musique]
lorsque vous reposer dans la terre rien
ne peut plus vous aider à part vos
bonnes actions passées
[Musique]